there's something undeniably
entertaining about watching actors mess
up a scene by flubbing a line breaking
character or even walking into a wall of
these classic movie bloopers are just as
entertaining as the film's they came
from in fact in some cases they're even
better and they've kept us cracking up
for years Smokey and the Bandit - more
than 35 years after the release of
Smokey and the Bandit - many comedies to
run a blooper reel over the closing
credits and from bandits credits it's
clear that stars Burt Reynolds and Sally
Field had a blast working on the film
[Music]
sadly in the year since a credits
blooper reel has actually become a
pretty reliable indicator that the movie
itself isn't all that funny
you're all home alone unless you're some
kind of monster there's not much that's
funny about watching a child get hurt
but when Macaulay Culkin slips on ice in
an outtake from the first home alone
film
well it's downright hilarious perhaps
it's because falling down is always
funny no matter who's doing the falling
North by Northwest in one of Alfred
Hitchcock's best films North by
Northwest Eva Marie Saint character
pulls out a gun in the crowded cafeteria
as suspenseful as it is viewers who pay
close attention will know ahead of time
that she's going to fire that gun that
saw thanks to a little boy in the
background who plugs his ears five
seconds too early
little fool for me back to the future in
this classic time-travel comedy Michael
J Fox is character Marty it takes a swig
from a bottle of booze while on a date
with Lorraine played by Lea Thompson to
his surprise some Back to the Future
associates decided to help him out by
filling it with actual liquor his
reaction was a hundred percent real and
he didn't seem too upset about it either
the frighteners before he moved on to
epic films like the Lord of the Rings
and King Kong Peter Jackson directed
this quirky horror movie about a guy who
develops the ability to communicate with
ghosts though Michael J Fox wanted
audiences to associate him with
something other than Back to the Future
it seems that even he had a hard time
doing that himself during the shoot when
speaking to the character named at the
judge Fox kept calling him dark as in
Doc Brown from Back to the Future
cooking the Pony Express RDoc I call him
doc doc doc I did it again we're the
Millers Jason Sudeikis Jennifer Aniston
Emma Roberts and will Poulter pretend to
be a family as part of a drug smuggling
operation and we're the Millers in one
scene today kisses character turns on a
radio and TLC's waterfalls are supposed
to play instead the cast and crew took
this opportunity to prank Aniston by
blasting the theme from friends instead
[Music]
Aniston's emotional reaction made it
totally worth it
laiá laiá jim carrey is an incredible
improviser and directors will often just
keep the cameras rolling and let him
experiment laiá laiá is one of Carey's
most over-the-top comedic performances
and while the filmmakers couldn't use
all of his hilarious improv in the film
they created a gag reel to play over the
credits
it's also quite a treat to watch cast
members club back at him with hilarious
moments of their own
Star Trek one thing unites the many Star
Trek properties from the original series
in the 1960s to the world expanding
shows in the 80s and 90s to the
big-budget film reboots of the 21st
century
spaceship doors never seemed to work
correctly centers are camping for
generations of these characters just
can't seem to exam room variant Raiders
of the Lost Ark the classic Indiana
Jones flick Raiders of the Lost Ark is a
film with a mistake that actually made
it into the final cut and there's kind
of a gross one so of course we can't
look away in an extreme close up on
actor Paul Freeman the camera catches a
fly landing on his face and crawling
right into his mouth your persistence
surprises even me
you're gonna give mercenaries a bad name
in an interview with fansite the indie
experience Freeman claims that the fly
never actually went into his mouth but
that's an editor played around with
frames to make it look like it dead the
effect is gross enough that there's
really one appropriate reaction
meanwhile another beloved movie has a
blooper that made its way into the final
cuts and as now as cherished a part of
the movie as any of its other parts Star
Wars probably because it's part of one
of the most successful and beloved
movies of all time the stormtrooper
bonking is had on a door frame during
Star Wars as one of the most famous
movie bloopers ever and it never gets
old it's a rare and welcome bit of
physical comedy in the otherwise
dramatic space opera
plus with stormtroopers constantly
getting themselves shots blown up and
are thrown around this minor mishap
really helps drive home the idea that
these faceless soldiers are the Imperial
Keystone Cops of outer space thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to